we've got X equal writing over died here
do I have any agreement at all yeah I
get I'm getting some dogs at the head
which is great one quick way of course
that we can check this being that as
they're working is that we can just take
that both X and substitute back it let's
just quickly do that right now the left
hand side if I put this everywhere I see
X will give me this when you multiply a
fraction by 3 rather doing the numerator
the first thing you should check is
killer cancel anything like will that
make things a bit easier and I can write
if I cancel this three with one of the
threes of the denominator what do I get
less with what's it cancels right that
threes God it leaves one of the threes
down here right like lead over three
take away one a fractured take away
something else what is your instinct to
do with that 1983 take away one how many
thirds are there in one how many thirds
are they there are three thirds right so
therefore I could write this as 1903
take away three over three
I don't have any thirds that's going to
be 16 thirds is that 16 thirds checks
out so good job Alex good
here's Leah is working you can see where
he's gone down he's more or less in fact
I'm pretty sure every single step he's
done he could have done had this bit of
equation not an inequality right do you
see what he's subtracted 2x from both
sides he added one to both sides he
simplified he what's he done on the very
last line of working from he didn't he's
divided by 2
everything looks good it is an
inequality so what might have been
different for example if this last slide
here was not to expert minus 2x what
would have gone differently on the last
line yeah ugly
yeah very good because we know that an
inequality could be true but if you
multiply divide by a negative number the
inequality is no longer facing of the
same direction it flips around okay but
luckily for you
everything was your E so just like an
equation and what do you think of his
other loan you look like a with that
yeah you've got the most important point
you've got the boundary I this circle
here is hollow why is that okay you
don't include the four it has two big in
it so more looks good
does anyone I mean you didn't color to
it sir but I'll put on the spot now did
anyone get an answer for three anyone
yeah Khushi okay let me move into space
X is 128 to get 2x equals 128 the tip
was we write this as an exponential it's
a log equation right now so if you can't
remember how to do this let me remind
you Exponential's are logs both of them
have a base see this one it's the lowest
number here for to the base it both is
the same so on the next line I'm going
to have 2 as the base load of a log of
an exponential these two doubles here
just gotta swap places so 2 to the 7
will be X you see how they've kind of a
done a bit of a switch there like so so
the base stays based on everything else
switches 2 to the 7 is 128 so there you
go okay any questions
happy times which rule that off and then
the heading out likely to make is
variation variation
now we're starting a [ __ ] topic today
and this topic is going to have lots of
drawings in it now I don't know how you
feel about drawings a lot of people
aren't cute about drawings because they
take a long time to do well but I really
like trees because you guys have heard
have you heard the phrase a picture
tells a thousand words you have that
phrase before right
very old phrase the whole idea is if you
could draw a good picture it conveys a
lot of visual information very quickly
which if you had to read it out in like
a paragraph something would take you
ages right so we're going to enjoy some
pictures today and they've got to be
based on this idea of variation so let
me tell you what this means variation
dot dot dot is when you have two
quantities that well in maths we're
interested in numbers that change right
this is why we introduced algebra
because very frequently we're not just
interested in numbers that are equal to
something particular but numbers that
can take on a range of different values
so when you've got two quantities that
change but they change in relationship
to one another let me say that again
there's two quantities let's you that
change in relationship to each other and
there's two ways that this can happen
firstly when one thing gets bigger when
one quantity gets bigger the other one
might get bigger along with it so as it
example ah excuse me the ball buddy I've
got some more donuts I can buy there's
two quantities okay the amount of cash
in my wallet
and how sick I'm going to feel after I
finish my dessert okay more money can
buy more donuts okay so here are two
quantities and you see they change your
relationship to each other
they both increase at the same time okay
so if both increase together
then we call this direct variation
they very directly in relation to each
other another word you may hear instead
of variation and I think in fact I think
the textbooks title for this is
proportion we would say that these
things are proportional to each other
the number of Donuts I can buy is
proportional the amount of money that I
have so this is a pretty straightforward
idea to get across but there are some
quantities you pair them up and in fact
is what increases the other one
decreases let me say that again rather
both increasing together sometimes a
pair of quantities will increase in one
and decrease in the other so ones
increase whoops
doesn't it Nestle the end leads to the
others decrease okay example the the
number of torques that are going to eat
versus the number of people I'd go to
share it with okay that make sense I'm
like oh I walk in with this box of
donuts I'm suddenly going to share it
with 31 people rather than one person
then the amount oh no I'm going to eat
is going to be smaller what they
increase the number of people who are
sharing therefore the other thing
decrease the amount that I always going
to eat or the allow that each individual
is going to be right we don't call this
direct variation we call this indirect
or inverse variation or just like before
you might see this word proportional so
you might see it called inversely
proportional
that should say directly proportional
sorry okay so you might like to just put
the example maybe you want to do a crude
drawing here dollars and donuts and then
this is that looks like zero dollars but
anyway I'm not very good at drawing
donuts
does that look more donut like yeah
looks like a donut right there we go
okay and I've down here this one where
what increases with the other decreases
I suppose I would put ball and do Knox
again okay visual arts never my strength
but you get the idea okay more money
equals more donuts for me to eat but
more people means less donut for me to
eat that's that's sad isn't it